die frage die mich bei diesem thema so
wahnsinnig bei diesem konkreten fall bei
dieser razzia so umtreibt sind junge
männer und die üben im wald mit äxten
und messern es gibt aber keine
festnahmen erklären sie sich dass oder
erklären sie es vielleicht auch er da
ein bisschen erstmal von mutmaßlichen
zelle das heißt wir brauchen natürlich
in einem rechtsstaat erstmal beweisen
und ich glaube dass die dass die
behörden jetzt jeder arbeit machen
mussten und hoffentlich wenn es wirklich
auch beweise dahinter gibt es auch zu
festen ankommen wird damit rechnen sie
gehe oder gehen sie davon aus dass es
dann welche weise müsste man da also die
beweislage es gab möglich dieses treffen
im wald müsste sich noch konkretisieren
und dann könnte es genau vielleicht auch
strukturen zu anderen
terrororganisationen
vielleicht auch kommunikation vielleicht
auch vorhaben materiellen die man
zuhause findet so funktioniert es im
rechtsstaat und da bin ich absolut
sicher dass in den letzten jahren vor
allem die polizei und staatsschutz sehr
sehr gut hinschauen und beweist er auch
dieser fall das ganz genau hingeschaut
wurde dass er ganz genau beobachtet
wurde mit wem kommunizieren diese männer
7 beispielsweise auch mit männern
kommuniziert die involviert waren in den
anschlag auf in wien also wir merken
dass der terror entwicklung in zwei
unterschiedliche richtungen sich
entwickelt wir sehen das immer noch
strukturen entstehen also mehrere
menschen die ideologisch treffen und
etwas vorbereiten das haben wir ja
unterschiedliche in unterschiedlichen
europäischen ländern immer wieder
gesehen dass es kein phänomen von
gestern auch in deutschland ist das
nicht neu wir haben mit terror gefahren
seid 2014 enten sie fast monatlich zu
tun solcherart sie uns solche
nachrichten kommen fast monatlich
zu zu sehen und darüber zu berichten
wir haben aber auch an andere
entwicklung und zwar einzelperson also
menschen die noch nie ein kontakt mit
den ef gehabt haben oder mit anderen
terrororganisationen die aber so
ideologisch darauf sind dass sie bereit
sind im namen dieser ideologie auch
gewalt anzuwenden und das haben wir in
deutschland wie zb in wien immer wieder
gesehen in dresden in hamburg in wien in
frankreich und das wird uns leider auch
in den nächsten jahren auch begleiten
diese radikalisierung von junger
menschen ist kein thema von gestern die
beschäftigt uns diejenigen die im
bereich islamismus arbeiten aber auch
natürlich die behörden wie polizei und
staatsschutz gibt so etwas wie so eine
typische radikalisierung biografie weil
mich irritiert dass immer wieder vor
allem das was themen da mitgebracht hat
auch an bildern aus düren das ist so
eine ja sehr
normale wohngegend würde ich sagen und
hinter den mauern in den häusern leben
plötzlich typen ganz jung die sich
radikalisieren die im wald trainieren
die kontakt aufnehmen offenbar gezielt
zu diesem jahr geistesverwandten und
attentätern von wien das heißt wie
passiert sowas in düren wo wir jetzt
sagen das gibt es doch gar nicht gibt es
eben doch alles
passiert in wien ist passiert in brüssel
wir haben immer die für ihre glaube
terroristen sind irgendwelche tora bora
taliban die durch die berge laufen oder
in syrien mit kalaschnikow
radikalisierung kann jeden treffen das
sind junge menschen auf der suche nach
orientierung und sie kommen meistens aus
zerstörten familien wir haben eine
persönliche krise wir haben ja in
unserer arbeit fast 500 biografien
sozusagen begleitet und analysiert und
das sind meistens jungen menschen die
auf der suche nach neuer anfang wir sind
unzufrieden mit ihrem leben und dann
kommt die verbindung so jemandem aus der
zehner der missioniert die bindung
schafft der der die vier jugendlichen
ihre sprache anspricht das sind kein
arabische ansprachen die darstellen das
sind deutsche die auch in der lage die
jugendkultur zu kennen und anzusprechen
wie schaffen bindung zu dieser
jugendliche und von da bis jugendlicher
sich radikalisieren es der weg für kurze
bieten ihnen zugehörigkeit so eine elite
wir bieten ihnen alternativen sie bieten
ihnen neuanfang und das funktioniert
leider im rechtsextremismus genauso wie
im islamismus und das ist ein thema die
leider uns auch in den nächsten jahren
begleiten wird für wie bedrohlich
empfinden sie schätzen sie die lage
derzeit in deutschland ein sehr
bedrohlich genauso wie in anderen
europäischen ländern es reicht ein
person der sich radikalisiert mit einem
messer oder in ein auto in nahmen diese
ideologie andere menschen verletzt und
das ist glaube ich nicht meine worte
sondern auch die worte von
innenministerium genau wie behörden die
sagen diese bedrohungslage ist massiv
und zwar seit jahren danke an den islam
und islamismus expertin ahmad mansour
hierbei bild live nachdem die polizei
dort all gestern in düren in nordrhein
westfalen eine große razzia durchgeführt
hat in der islamistenszene
möglicherweise eine terrorzelle dort
ausgehoben vernichtet